en este vídeo vamos a reflexionar como
las fracciones se pueden usar para
representar cosas en el mundo real
esta vez nos dicen en el equipo de buceo
tiburones hay tres buzos en tercer grado
el equipo tiene ocho pozos en total qué
fracción del equipo de buzos tiburones
está en tercer grado pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar la respuesta
muy bien primero nos dicen que hay ocho
buzos en total así que vamos a
representar cada buzo con un pequeño
círculo como este intentaré que se
parezca un poco a un buzo y aunque no es
un círculo creo que tienes la idea
parece un buzo descendiendo tenemos 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8
ahora sí solo trabajamos con un solo
buzo éste sería un buzo de 8 oa menudo
le llamaríamos un octavo o podemos
representarlo como un octavo todo en
letra o podemos escribirlo como un
octavo solo en números este es uno de
los ocho miembros del equipo de buzos
ahora nos dicen hay tres buzos en tercer
grado qué fracción del equipo de buzos
tiburones está en tercer grado bueno
digamos que son estos tres entonces hay
tres de los ocho si quieres representar
esto como fracción o puedes hacerlo como
tres octavos
de esta forma o si los quieres
representar de manera escrita en lugar
de tener tres sobre ocho podemos
escribir tres octavos
si haces esto en khan academy habrá
algunas opciones por allí donde podrás
elegir la opción correcta pero si
pensamos en qué fracción del equipo de
buzos tiburones está en tercer grado la
opción correcta ya sea que esté
representada como 3 sobre 8 o como 3
octavos o 3 y la palabra octavos hagamos
otro ejemplo nos dicen
yolanda divide su plastilina en cuatro
partes iguales y hace animales de
plastilina con tres de esas partes que
fracción de la plastilina total usa
yolanda para hacer animales una vez más
pausa el vídeo y piensa en ello
bueno vamos a pensar que inicialmente
esta es su plastilina y la va a dividir
en cuatro partes iguales en cada una de
estas partes tienen la misma cantidad de
plastilina este es un dibujo a mano y
aunque no es perfecto vamos a suponer
que cada una de las partes tienen la
misma cantidad de plastilina ahora dice
que ella hace animales de plastilina con
tres de esas partes tal vez con esta
parte de plastilina animales tal vez
esta sea otra de las partes que utiliza
para hacer animales y esta otra la
utiliza para hacer animales entonces qué
fracción de la plastilina usó para ser
animales bueno como le llamamos a cada
una de estas partes si nos enfocamos
solo en esta parte de aquí las
llamaríamos un cuarto
o podemos representarla como un cuarto o
como un cuarto
esto representa lo que circulamos solo
una de estas partes iguales
puede ser ésta o ésta o ésta o ésta si
hablamos de toda la plastilina de qué
estamos hablando
bueno podremos pensar toda la plastilina
como cuatro cuartos o cuatro sobre
cuatro que también se lee como cuatro
cuartos nos referimos a todas estas
cuatro partes de la plastilina una dos
tres cuatro ahora bien si queremos
reflexionar en qué fracción de la
plastilina total osa yolanda para ser
animales podemos ver que tres de las
cuatro partes se utilizan para hacer
animales así que la respuesta será tres
de los cuartos
yolanda utiliza tres cuartos para hacer
animales de plastilina o también podemos
expresarla como fracción podemos
escribir tres cuartos de esta manera
estas dos expresiones a selena igual
tres cuartos o tres cuartos y
representan lo mismo tres de las cuatro
partes iguales de la plastilina que
yolanda uso para hacer animales